hey youtubers is Charlie this video is
gonna be my breakdown of the Walking
Dead Season 5 trailer hopefully you guys
have had a chance to see that Comic Con
footage that I posted over the weekend
but basically that footage they showed
during that panel is the trailer that
you guys have seen or hopefully you've
seen it AMC is really nice about posting
it immediately after the panel the
movies that were there like Avengers 2
Batman vs Superman they do not release
their clips I have no idea why but the
Walker [ __ ] has just hit the fan in case
you guys just found me during Comic Con
or you're just finding me now I do
weekly Walking Dead videos be sure to
subscribe to get everything
I'll explain who the winner of my
giveaway is at the end of this video so
a trailer time they pick up right in
that last moment of the season 4 finale
Rick's final line before it cut to the
credits they have this crazy inception
trailer music that a lot of people have
been using recently that wah sound is
really crazy
I think the Godzilla trailer did the
same thing it just meant to put you into
this state of anxiety and I say mission
accomplished on the plus side they did
crank the lighting up it's like you can
actually see people's faces inside that
train car during the finale they shot
that in like complete darkness
I had to scoot up to my TV just to see
who was still alive it basically looks
like they tear-gassed the train car
before storming in to subdue everyone
but from the looks of it
everyone just bolts the minute they get
the chance all in the first few minutes
of episode 1 then we get a little bit of
confirmation on the whole cannibal thing
that table that Rick sees as he hits the
ground it's pretty safe to say that
that's a body being carved up there just
like you'd see someone carve a side of
beef more steaks for the grill unless
you want some ribs you do not want the
ribs gareth has this cool creepy
monologue where he starts speechifying
his new way of life actor Andrew J West
did that interview on talking dead where
he said that Gareth has like this weird
new philosophy about life after the
apocalypse and how it can be he made it
sound super creepy and at the time they
had not confirmed all that cannibalism
at terminus but I think that's exactly
what his new way of life is then they
basically just line everyone up like
they're gonna slaughter them like pigs
this trough that you see them hanging
their heads over that's for collecting
blood it looks pretty much like Bob
talks their way out of it like he just
talks faster than I talked after three
cups of coffee that's pretty goddamn
fast but it looks like Gareth buys into
Eugene's cure idea in the Washington DC
trip it jump cuts to some generic
terminus shots until Rick is with baby
freakin Judith reunion time
lujah that just confirms that Carol
Tyrese Mason in okay but we see a lot of
different scenes later in the trailer so
I'm just gonna do this as we go along
then we see him on the road again with
the weapons cache I was pretty sure they
weren't just gonna drop that story bit
like a hidden arsenal of automatic
weapons
Rick's tearing down a terminus poster so
I think is just foreshadowing the fall
of terminus then we get full on Rick
action hero I just love how Rick looks
like Mel Gibson in the road warrior in
this slow-motion shot which is funny
because they actually showed footage
from that new Mad Max movie at Comic Con
too so if it wasn't clear earlier you
can definitely see in these next couple
of scenes they're inside a church and a
lot of these moments since gareth is the
only person with them it looks like
they've left terminus at this point
whenever they're in these church scenes
so you can see the trailer just jumping
backwards and forwards in time I think
it's all just taken from the first
couple of episodes typically trailers do
not use moments from too far in advance
unless it's Game of Thrones Game of
Thrones actually uses moments from the
trailer all the way up to the finale
it's crazy this fire hose Walker
repellant doesn't look like it's
happening at terminus but the thing that
grabs my eye is that it looks like Terra
is just casually sitting off to the side
it might not be her it could be someone
totally different but it's definitely
not a walker it's just someone there
that's enjoying the water show in the
talking dead special lauren cohan said
there are a couple of weaklings in the
group that gets to be badasses in the
premiere based on Bob Stokey going on me
shown on this Walker I'm guessing she
was talking about him he's come a long
way from that time Daryl almost pushed
him off the roof so let me get some nice
callbacks to the early episodes in
season 4
look at this shopping mall pit - hell
it's a nice twist on the walkers falling
from the ceiling last year all that
water and the walkers in it reminds me
of the governor's piranha tank Glen
Mazzara did say that they developed a
lot of new looking walkers we haven't
seen before and this guy actually looks
pretty new like melty face Walker here
I'm totally digging the car Lemmy shown
team up I hope she teaches him to use
that sword some point this year it looks
like she's modified it to be double
ended which is just awesome this
nighttime exterior shot is just that
church that we've seen everyone inside
and all the other scenes Rick talks
about not going anywhere without the
rest of the survivors jumps back to
terminus back to the church and then
sasha says you know you show up and then
three of us are gone she's talking about
Abraham Rosita and Eugene whenever they
showed up last season she didn't meet
them till terminus but the ones so far
that are gone are bad
Lizzie and mica she doesn't know the
BET's still alive and so here is where
all hell breaks loose at terminus just
look at all the walkers in the flames I
just love this explosion I cannot
imagine how many barrels of gasoline
they had to burn to get the flame that
big that just have they accomplished
special effects like that they basically
just light giant tanks of gasoline on
fire and they make flames really big
this person does look like a new ginger
but I think it's just Carol covering
herself in mud on approach to terminus
and so here's this scene that everyone's
been freaking out about Glenn almost
getting a baseball bat to the back of
the head at terminus it's just because
of the comics I'm not gonna spoil what
happens but it's pretty WTF I don't
think he dies or anything because he's
in a lot of those other scenes in the
trail that looked like they happened
after that moment at terminus like after
they've left terminus remember the
trailers jumping around in time the
baseball bat scene looks like it's from
whenever they first get yanked up to
that trough whenever Bob Stokey stops
them from getting all their throats slit
Scott Gimple did say they would continue
to have a rotating cast this season but
I'll explain what that means later
here's our first look at Seth Gilliam as
Father Gabriel I know the minute he was
cast everyone wondered if he was gonna
be playing Gabriel from the comics just
because he kind of resembled him they
did confirm that during the comic-con
panel so I'm assuming that church that
they're at is his church the real twist
is that it looks like he did not take
Beth like he had nothing to do with Beth
she hasn't been in any of the church
scenes and she shows up with a different
group later in the trailer then we come
back to badass Rick I love in all these
random shots how he's holding a machine
gun let's just agree to call him machine
gun Rick this year and so then we
finally get a look at the other big
location it's like the second terminus
type place that they're gonna be filming
at during season five or they're still
filming at it's a hospital and they have
been filming there a lot so it seems
like based on the number of days they've
been shooting Beth is gonna stay there
for a long time
no idea where it's located on the map
relative to terminus so this person is
one of the new cast members who I'm just
gonna call a lady cop for now
or maybe [ __ ] lady cop her real name
in real life is Christine woods but we
do not know what her character's name is
yet or if it ties into the comics Scott
Gimple did reveal that these people that
took Beth they're the ones behind the
crosses he said that even though they
invoke a lot of imagery from the
Savior's in the comics they are not the
Savior's so that lady
is not gonna be lady negan even though
the idea of a gender bent negan gets me
really excited but let me know what do
you think about the idea of a gender
bent negan would you totally go for that
or do you think it's a terrible idea
that's a whole lot of Lady f-bombs
but best storyline is supposed to be
pretty substantial like way bigger than
it's ever been in the past and it's
gonna take place away from the rest of
the survivors at least for a while so
I'm guessing that that hospital that
she's at is the home base of the Cross
people or whatever they're gonna call
themselves so I'm just gonna talk a
little bit about the actual escape from
terminus cuz it looks like that might
all go down in that first episode based
on the way the scenes in the trailer
were cut it seems like riggan the group
gag Gareth to buy into the Washington DC
cure story so he lets them go to pursue
it but Rick turns them around so that
they don't have to you know
quote-unquote leave anyone behind then
they grab the weapons cache and let the
walkers in and blow the place to hell
Gareth is a cast regular this season so
for whatever reason it seems like he
convinces Rick to take him with them I'm
gonna think of him as like the little
finger of the group this season from
Game of Thrones if you don't watch that
show just think of him as like a person
that no one trusts who is a super
creeper but let me know what your
favorite WTF moment from the trailer was
and who do you think that lady cop is do
you think she's like lady negan or
someone else but Walking Dead is back
Sunday October 12 I will be doing the
weekly videos as I did for it just like
I did during season 4 the weekly
giveaway it's probably gonna overlap
with my Doctor Who giveaway you guys
will just have more chances to win free
[ __ ] it'll be awesome
real quick shout out to the winner of my
Comic Con giveaway Congrats to the
yelling Fox you win a Walking Dead Funko
pop figure of your choice I'll message
you on your channel for details so be
sure to check your inbox my next Walking
Dead bonus video is gonna be a character
breakdown for Daryl because if you look
at him pre Beth disappearance and in the
trailer he looks like he's going through
a massive transformation just like Rick
is kind of gone back to being a badass
there gonna be a lot of characters
swinging from one end of the spectrum to
the other I'll try to post that video
either like Sunday or Monday right now
though click here if you have not seen
The Walking Dead Comic Con panel is
really cool and click here to get my
breakdown of the Batman vs Superman
footage they also played a Comic Con
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tomorrow high fives
you